I'm going to show you two very short
adverts my question is which is louder
this video is sponsored by nordvpn this
video is sponsored by nordvpn
here's the volume of the nice calm one
the second one with the shouting the
background noise the music if you're
measuring volume purely by decibels then
it was lower but it definitely sounded
louder to explain that we need to start
at the beginning what does it mean for
something to be loud
let's say a tree falls in the forest the
tree causes the air to move both by
pushing it out the way but also by the
tree and the things around it vibrating
as they deal with all the forces
involved those vibrations are
transferred into the air the actual air
itself is not traveling from the
crushing tree to your ears but rather
it's a wave caused by air molecules
bumping into each other and if you're
standing nearby then bits of that wave
get funneled by the Flappy bit of the
air the Pinner into your ear canal the
waves get your eardrum and it vibrates
in turn just a tiny tiny amount behind
it there's the three smallest bones in
the human body the hammer and volt and
Stirrup they amplify those vibrations
through leverage and deliver those
vibrations into the cochlea shaped like
a snail shell which converts it into
electrical impulses they get interpreted
by the brain if you ask a physicist
those air movements are sound ask a
psychologist and we'll say that until
those movements get interpreted by the
brain it's just stuff moving because
sound is in your head it's an experience
if the tree falls in the forest and no
one's there to listen a physicist says
the sound a psychologist says there
isn't and both of them are correct
because they're using the same word to
mean different things which is part of
why it takes so long to answer what
seems like a simple question so let's
talk about that Wave It's got two
important values the amount of pressure
for each Peak the amplitude and the time
between each Peak arriving the frequency
we'll start with the amplitude pressure
is measured in pascals and regular Air
at about sea level has a pressure of
somewhere around a hundred thousand
pascals that's the weight of all the
atmosphere above pushing down our ears
can detect a fluctuation of about 20
micropascals a whisper in your ear would
be about two millipascals and traffic
noise about 200 millipascals and
someone's screaming at the top of their
voice directly into your ear is around
20 pascals which is well into the sorts
of pressure that can cause hearing loss
okay as you might have noticed that's
not a particularly useful graph because
the differences in scale are enormous
even if we get rid of the ambient
pressure at the top so instead let's use
a logarithmic scale which means that
each block going vertically is 10 times
the previous one that's much clearer
just remember this is a 10 times jump in
pressure and so is this and so is this
that's how decibels work the minimum
that humans can detect 20 micropascals
is taken as zero bells and then each 10
times increase in pressure adds Two
Bells and we generally use tenths of
those so each 10 times increase is
another 20 decibels and I know a load of
sound engineers and techies are already
in the comments going no no no I each 10
times increases is 10 decibels you you
fall and there's reason two why this is
so difficult to answer there are
multiple decibel scales because sound
Engineers talk about intensity the
amount of power transmitted not the
amount of actual pressure on your
eardrum those two things are
proportional and okay it doesn't matter
for this just blame mathematicians okay
the important thing is your brain
doesn't interpret 10 times more change
in pressure to mean 10 times as loud
sure traffic noise feels louder than a
whisper but I don't think many people
would guess that the amplitude is a
hundred times greater that's why we use
decibels a logarithmic scale matches how
we think about sound
hold that thought that's amplitude dealt
with next is frequency and that's easy
to Define it's just the number of Peaks
per second or Hertz the human ear can
detect roughly from 20 Hertz 2 to 20 000
Hertz although that starts to decrease
as people get older the sound wave is
going to be much more complex of course
it's usually not transmitting just a
single frequency but let's not get into
the maths of that too much
we're particularly sensitive to the
range between two thousand and five
thousand Hertz which means our brains
perceive those frequencies as being
louder in 1933 Harvey Fletcher and
William Munson published this
which became known as the Fletcher
Munson curve they play different sounds
at different levels and noted how their
test subjects perceived that sound the
curve has been updated and refined over
time and now it's usually called the
equal loudness Contour
so if you want this tone
and this tone
to feel as loud as each other you need
to play the low one I want to say louder
but that's not right you need to play
the low one with greater amplitude and
of course science has a measuring system
for this too audio engineers and
broadcast companies came up with lots
loudness units full scale the
calculations for this take the loudest
Contour into account along with how long
the loud sounds last lufts are a
scientific way to measure how loud
something should feel not how much the
air happens to be moving if you're
making a video for YouTube or Netflix or
music for Spotify or iTunes there are
guides for you to follow YouTube asks
you to aim for -14 lufts the units are
kind of arbitrary it's just a number if
you upload something that's louder than
that they'll just turn the player's
volume setting down automatically in the
background so people don't suddenly get
started with one video or music track is
louder than another so that means if
you're making a movie or a TV show and
you want your loud sounds to have impact
you can't turn them up above the limit
you have to turn the dialogue and speech
all the other sounds down not too much
that'll also cause problems but enough
that when the big explosion happens it's
noticeable it's Audible
but advertisers don't need or want the
Nuance they just want to be heard they
usually want to be as loud as they can
be throughout
the European Union specifies minus 23
Lofts as its Target for broadcasters to
try and keep adverts and programs at the
same loudness the US has no specific
guidelines but says that broadcasters
should try to match the two although
that rule is rarely if ever enforced all
of which is to say that the whisper of
that first advert the sound waves had
higher amplitude your eardrum will have
vibrated further back and forth but it
didn't feel as loud there were more
decibels but fewer lefts and these days
it's the laughs that matter
seriously this nordvpn advert has lower
sound pressure than this one does and
I'm happy to endorse Lord VPN because I
keep finding it actually useful some
American sites block European visitors
entirely because they can't bother to
deal with the privacy laws over here or
maybe you want to access content without
your internet provider or
just check the streaming services terms
and conditions first
on your phone tablet and computer up to
six devices at a time and it's a 30-day
money-back guarantee if you want to test
it out
or scan the QR code to find the best
deal they're currently offering my voice
is tired
also it's really hot out